well folks it finally happened fallen
the godfather of brazilian
counter-strike and
former leader of the all too illustrious
sk luminosity lineup
is making his triumphant return where is
he headed you ask
to north america well europe
i guess technically to be the new opping
igl
of team liquid
[Music]
okay so before we dive into the episode
i just wanted to let you guys know that
if you'd like to see me up here more
often doing cs go don't at me's
please let me know in the comments and
that the best thing you can do to
support the channel
is subscribe you'll notice that we're at
like 1.5 million subs on the road to 2
million
i'd really like to hit that before the
next cs go major so
let's make that happen okay so even
though it was leaked ages ago and we all
knew it was going to happen
on saturday team liquid announced their
newest acquisition
fallen i chose to play in liquid because
i have been playing against those guys
for so many years since i came to an a
and i know their strengths i know how
well they can play and i think with my
abilities and the way i think about the
game it can be helpful
and be what they're looking for now if
you've never heard of fallen which
hey look fortnite kitties watch these
videos too he is the legendary opping
igl who led brazil's
greatest roster to two back-to-back
major wins in 2016.
needless to say this dude is pretty much
an institution
in addition to shepherding such
superstar talents as coldzera
he spent a lot of his life doing wonders
for the brazilian scene at large
he even boasts his own line of gaming
peripherals people in brazil
pretty much worship this guy and with
good reason there was a time
when he could not be stopped you have a
believer
would you suggest that you don't want to
stop believing
why don't you cast the round okay tax up
one he's gonna get back
i'm starting to believe as well henry
because he's gonna take inflation
stop blowing my mind problem of course
is that that was
some time ago since rebranding as mibr
about midway through 2018
fallen and his band of trusty brazilian
bruisers
really began to fall off for almost two
years they delivered subpar results
looking like a
shadow of their former selves that drove
their star fragger coldzera to leave the
lineup in the fall of 2019
which of course only made things worse
their breaking point came in the fall of
2020
when after the org decided to bench fur
taco
and their longtime coach dead fallen
expressed his frustration
by benching himself which brings us to
right now about four months later
when it's being announced that fallen is
joining team liquid
the question of course is i'm just gonna
say it
izzy washed now look it's way too early
to tell
at this point but rumor has it this dude
has been looking
crispy as [ __ ] in the scrims he's been
playing
i'm gonna have to kill that one first
it's nice i have marked exit has the
cross
leg yeah one is slurp flashing
the other one have right side out both
[Music]
sides left side crossing side
oh my god and the reality is that fallen
is a
born leader and if there's one thing
that liquid are in
desperate need of right now it's someone
to call the shots
it's no secret that liquid have been in
something of a downward spiral since
becoming the greatest north american
roster ever about midway through 2019.
it's also no secret that they've done
pretty much everything
under the sun to fix it all to no avail
it didn't matter that they replaced
their coach adren
with moses or that they called up an
unproven up-and-comer named grimm
to replace that muscly dude who just won
the valor major
liquid were still not great
better maybe but not by much
so from a leadership standpoint the
fallen acquisition makes a
ton of sense right now the roster is
being led by stewie
who despite having a tremendous mind for
the game
is really more of a mid-round caller
than an actual igl
this will free up the so-called smoke
criminal to
lurk cause chaos and just be creative
with how he frags
stewie is at his best when he's well
a bit of a [ __ ] disturber shifting the
bulk of the leadership responsibilities
on to fallen
should enable him to bm to his heart's
content now you might be wondering
who exactly did falwen replace well
honestly that's the biggest downside to
all of this
somebody had to go and liquid clearly
felt they had no choice but to part ways
with russell twists vanduulkin aside
from having
staggeringly excellent hair and being
the
sweetest cs go player i have ever had
the pleasure of interviewing
twists carries the distinction of being
a
world class gamer you decide stewie oh
he goes down and nitro is gone as well
and twist in the corner there should be
no way out my god
how has he done it picking up a quick
triple and he's gonna win the round
absolutely godlike
unfortunately it seems as if the
transition to online
hit him harder than most since his
performance
kind of plummeted still he was a long
time member of the roster and
at his best represented a significant
portion of liquid's overall fragging
power
even if you have somebody like elige
doing disgusting
unthinkable things with spray patterns
it's risky to sacrifice such a skilled
hard-nosed
rifler for an opping igl fortunately
fallen appears to be aware of that he's
such a skilled mechanical player
that's for sure i'm not so i'm not gonna
be hitting the same shots twists have
been hitting before
but i think i bring other qualities and
i think i'm gonna be playing on
different roles than twist was playing
so sashimi won't be able to play with
him that would be very cool but i wish
him the best
anything he's going to do in the future
i hope he stays in cs and still
shows how good he is at this game the
problem of course is that liquid
needed a primary opera badly
in fact it felt like one of the reasons
for their inconsistency
was the fact that they'd somehow managed
to accrue three
secondary offers stew naf and nitro
all of whom were very proficient with
the weapon but none of whom were
die hard devotees okay so will the
fallen transfer pan out
who knows i will be the first to agree
that something
needed to change and that if liquid were
ever gonna
truly get the better of furia bringing
on a brazilian mastermind
was probably the best way of doing that
memes aside
i have a good feeling about this roster
i think that a lot of liquids
floundering had to do with the fact that
for a long time they simply had too many
superstars
at some point they started playing too
selflessly
and without a series of clearly defined
roles to rely on
who gets the op for instance quickly
found themselves spiraling out of
control
hopefully fallen can fix that by
instilling within them a sense of
direction
as for where twists ends up well
that's where things get exciting see cs
goes in a bit of a roster mania right
now
fnatic benched flusha who's apparently
building a roster with automatic
cloud9 benched walk sick and maus are
rumored to be replacing kerrigan
it is pandemonium right now and honestly
twists could find a home in a lot of
places
wherever our good old canadian boy finds
himself we'll be here to talk about it
it's starting to look as if the fallen
acquisition is just the first in a
series of momentous
roster moves and i for one am very
excited to see
what happens next yeah i know i i think
you know like it'd be cool i think if
maybe
like uh like that it's a really fun game
really enjoy it like maybe if they like
touch
like the the rifle sprays a little bit
and literally as soon as you finish your
sentence there's just
75 [ __ ] boomer sounding zoomers who
come out in the comments like well cs
goes a dead game
like it's a dead game bro like [ __ ] you
you're tilted you're salty man you're
just salty because cs goes dead
like no i'm salty because my [ __ ]
rifle sucks
i'm [ __ ] salty because it can't
[ __ ] hit [ __ ] there's like almost
like legitimately like
you cut out
now you're just going
do you drop out the call
you may have dropped out of the call he
may have dropped out of the call bro
rip